I can't come introduce the Civil War
without Captain America are you guys as
excited about Captain America's Civil
War's I am you're probably not but I'm
gonna make you excited we have some big
news from the annual Disney fan Expo d23
now while Disney probably won't show any
official footage for a while we have
been as vigilant as Falcons and keeping
our eyes peeled like hawk eyes and I
wish there were more birthday Avengers
for this to work anyway I'm drew
Coolidge and here's what we learned
about civil war at d23 this is hashtag
news so what was civil war about well
while some say it was about slavery in
states rights others say was about the
Avengers living up taking sides and
going head to head an all-out superhero
war so there's two teams team Iron Man
and team Captain America so team Iron
Man believes that the superheroes need
someone to watch them and that is going
to be the government now of course Tony
Stark's cool with this cuz he's been
wide open with who he is and what's
going on team Captain America doesn't
trust the government every time someone
tries to win a war before it starts
innocent people die isn't nothing why we
fight so we can end the fight so we get
to go home all that stuff happened to me
in Winter Soldier I wouldn't trust the
government either difficult as this is
to accept Captain America is a fugitive
from shield who will side with whom who
will fight with whom who will win with
whom is whom the right word to use there
we're here to find out and just so you
know there are some ant-man spoilers
you've been warned here we go
now Falcon has a new suit and a new toy
a flying drone machine named Red Wing
this is an adaptation of the comic book
Falcons Red Wing which had a real bird
that the hero shared a telepathic link
with this is an interesting update
because in the movie Falcon has more of
a military background no one in the
military likes birds they all love
drones
he's also announced that Captain America
Falcon and Black Widow will be going up
against crossbow this is Frank grumble
oh remember this guy
he was a guy who fought Falcon at the
end of Winter Soldier he's back so he
got his body crushed his face scarred
from a giant building falling on it but
in this one he gets a ton of new weapons
and gadgets he has enough firepower to
go up against team Captain America they
show a clip where he taunts cap with a
jab about Bucky the amnesia stricken
Winter Soldier from the previous movie
don't touch that nerve crossbow you're
gonna get a whuppin Kevin Merc stop next
up is an old character showing up from
the good old days general Thunderbolt
Ross played by William Hurt you might
remember general Thunderbolt from a 2008
Incredible Hulk which stars Edward
Norton as Bruce Banner not Mark Ruffalo
he appears and tries to seed out into
Captain America referring to the
Avengers as vigilantes now Bucky aka the
Winter Soldier is back in his amnesia
seems to be gone all that brainwashing
is just washed away in the ant-man
post-credits scene which is actually a
scene from Civil War we see Captain and
Falcon coming to rescue Bucky they're
probably gonna team up in Civil War
my money's on Bucky being on Captain
Team America
Black Panther shows up in full glory and
we haven't seen any footage but we have
seen some behind the scene set pics
using this character they're actually
using civil war as the introduction to
Black Panther before he gets his own
spin-off flicks also giant news Black
Widow and Hawkeye split up the super spy
BFF duo are on different sides of the
war and win widow asked if they're still
friends Hawkeye responds with depends on
how hard you hit me which sounds like
playful banter but in the comics Black
Widow and Hawkeye are at each other's
throats is it going to get that serious
in Civil War we don't know yet but we do
know they're gonna be on opposite sides
and men played by Paul Rudd shows up as
well
he meets Captain America in a scene that
showed at D 3 and he's goes full-out
fanboy he's gushing he's nervous it
starts touching cat's pecs like in the
first Captain America movie now this
might be a fanboy moment or it might be
some sort of test that Captain America
puts everyone through to be on his team
touch my pecs if you can survive you can
be on my team makes sense but the
question we all want to know where
spider-man everyone thought they were
gonna see spider-man at this d23 actor
Tom Holland joined pretty recently and
the fact that they don't want to show
the footage yet makes sense they can
kind of make that big reveal a little
closer to the release date personally
I've never been happier than the day
they announced that spider-man was even
gonna be in Civil War I can't wait to
see him play with all the other Marvel
superheroes now this was some of the
biggest Marvel news of the Expo Civil
War looks to be like the hero a hero
battle we've all been craving oh it
doesn't hit till May so subscribe we're
gonna be following this all the way til
May go ahead and comment with which
characters you want to show up
personally I would like some more bird
related ones to help me with my puns is
Eagle face a character if that's not
taken I'm taking it I'm Eagle face this
is hashtag news there well everybody
cockatoos in trouble Eagle face away
alright I just choked on what my own
spit it's hard to do this